and now the end is near and so I face
the final curtain what the hell walk it
off Lululemon I'll say it clear I'll
state my case of which I'm certain
alive I travel
live every day like it's your last bite
me i'ma live forever [ __ ] ma'am it's at
1:32 21 so big plans this weekend yep
I'm gonna sit alone in my house watching
wedding fails on YouTube drinking
margaritas through a twizzler straw
until I pass out on top of my vibrator
talk about the environment no buzz off
whale humper you know I see you here all
the time and you're always mean to me
and it really hurts my feelings it does
because the minute you're out of my line
of sight
I literally forget you exist what you
exist you don't exist they're bothering
me don't care if you die see why are you
like this
excuse me why am I like this no means
you don't know what I'm like
look what you made me do Jagga oh good
you're awake
can I ask you a question about where
we're going sure where are we going I
forgot we're going somewhere that's not
the good place and it's not the bad
place we're going to a medium place mmm
is there a 7-eleven on the way because
Jenna's powers aren't working and I want
some gum and some football cards and
some scratchy tickets go away from okay
you